well this is a weird question but I
understand there's a few masturbation
scenes there well easier to practice out
a lot that made it really difficult this
one only has one I told myself I was
gonna put it but it does oh ma it's
definitely r-rated stuff there's stuff
that's even stranger than masturbation
season in some ways I think it's even
edgier than my first edge year for me
bill use the word add to describe sex
but it's not there's no nudity there's
no sex in it but there's like
uncomfortable moments in it there's
stuff that I'm like okay I hope they're
memorable because it's cut their
unexpected turns in it but it's also got
it takes a pretty clean you know it also
deals with religious themes a lot not
until sort of the second half of the
film but you know that makes people or
nervous and it doesn't pop in fact I
think it's really respectful I had no
agenda with the religious approach in at
all but it deals with that and it did
like I said before didn't wear saris his
voice I'd sleep I hope it's like in his
spirit but it isn't his it doesn't take
any of his jokes and put them
immediately on screen it doesn't deliver
that much on sort of the wish
fulfillment of unfortunately David
Sedaris fans have really liked it and
got what we were going 400 if
appreciated that we didn't just take it
throw it up on screen that you know we
really put it through a process and that
I've made in my own it seems like most
of his fans appreciate that um but it
made it hard for people to understand
exactly what the movie was going to be
like and I would imagine my next phone
will prolly be just as hard you know to
get to get going so
you